[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peut-être que je reviens,
je viens de quitter le centre médical Walter Reed
et c'est vraiment
quelque chose de très spécial, les médecins, les
infirmières, les premiers intervenants
et j'ai tellement appris sur le coronavirus
et une chose est certaine, ne le
laissez pas
vous dominer.  n'ayez pas peur de ça
vous allez le battre nous avons le meilleur
équipement médical nous avons les meilleurs
médicaments
tous développés récemment et vous allez le
battre j'y suis allé je ne me sentais pas si bien
et il y a deux jours j'aurais pu  parti
il ​​y a deux jours il y a deux jours je me sentais bien comme
mieux que je ne l'ai été depuis longtemps j'ai dit
tout récemment
mieux qu'il y a 20 ans ne le laisse pas
dominer
ne le laisse pas prendre le contrôle de ta vie ne
laisse pas cela arriver
nous  avoir le plus grand pays du
monde nous retournons
nous retournons au travail nous allons
être devant en tant que votre chef je devais le faire
je savais qu'il y avait un danger mais je devais le
faire je me suis démarqué  avant
j'ai conduit personne qui est un leader
ne ferait pas ce que j'ai fait et je sais
qu'il y a un risque t  voici un danger mais
ça va
et maintenant je vais mieux et peut-être que je suis immunisé
je ne sais pas
mais ne le laissez pas dominer votre vie sortez faites
attention nous avons les meilleurs médicaments
au monde
et tout s'est passé très  sous peu et
ils sont tous approuvés
et les vaccins arrivent momentanément
merci beaucoup et walter reed
quel groupe de personnes merci beaucoup